on parle bien sûr de sdf ce soir est une
association qui nous tient à coeur qui
s'appelle les anges de la rue vous savez
ça fait 20 ans ils viennent de
montélimar j'aimerais qu'on accueille
les deux patrons des anges de la rue est
également natacha qui est avec merci
[Applaudissements]
bassam abb ça à ma chérie ça va être
tout ça en gros ça vous rend mère chérie
merci d'être là alors merci d'état alors
oui alors je vous présente ils font un
travail magnifique
voilà elle sait les anges de la rue ça
fait 20 ans que vous travaillez vous
venez vous avez fait un travail
formidable en robert tu peux nous dire
en deux dans deux minutes
voilà bah nous on s'est engagé à ce qu'
avant 2023 y ait plus personne dans la
rue on va clé de résidence un peu
partout en région parisienne dans le sud
des résidences qui peuvent être des
milliers de personnes ont très vite fait
d'un crier tous les jours voilà ça c'est
une des petits protégés qui est depuis
parce qu'un an à la maison qui servait
comme alors c'est natacha kaki est
magnifique natacha les entends sainte de
cinq mois tu as appris ce matin que
c'était six mois et ben j'en enlève un
signe a marqué cinq mois c'est que ces
cinq mois comme ça vu d'oeil ces six
mois je confirme tu as vingt ans tu as
appris ce matin que c'était une petite
fille oui c'est ça et c'est vrai que toi
tu étais tu étais dans la rue c'est vrai
que les anges dans les anges de la rue
tonton beau coupé dès qu'elle est c'est
quoi ton quotidien
bah mon coach tient dans l'association
umam et voilà oui c'est dans le thé dans
la rue quand on fait comment tu te
retrouver dans la rue j'étais en froid
avec ma mère depuis quelques années oui
au final à 18 ans elle a décidé de me
mettre dehors
donc j'ai dû me débrouiller tout seul
pendant 30 ans et demi avant de trouver
l'association et c'est dur surtout pour
une fille parce qu'il faut essayer de
faire un soir d'être protégé d'avoir des
endroits protégés programme mire de pas
montrer aux gens que quand galère comme
ça moi je fais pas agresser on n'est pas
assez ça on avait un problème mais c'est
dur pour une fille surtout le l'hygiène
et tout ce qui s'ensuit c'est alors je
sais que tu es hyper inquiète parce que
par rapport à la naissance de la petite
alors j'ai un petit cadeau pour toi qui
es là voilà c'est un petit cadeau voilà
qu'a fait la production
tu veux que je loue à ses bottes
singinois là alors je vais te dire c'est
un petit cadeau qu'on a prévu pour la
petite
alors je suis toujours très mal les
cadeaux
voilà c'est bien bravo les mecs c'est
une bonne taille et merci basile moreau
facilement l ouvreur alors tu vois là
alors on a bon là on a pensé voilà c'est
voilà c'est une petite maison de poupée
avec voilà avec donc les poussettes
berceau les habits tout ça merci
beaucoup je peux regarder un voilà chez
la petite maison voilà bon sauf que tout
ça bien entendu entre l'offre en vrai
voilà comme ça tu seras tranquille pour
l'afrique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gants et et dense est dans cette
maison dans cette maison il y avait une
clé y avait une clé parce que c'était
elle est pas anodine puisque on t'offre
également pour tu sois tranquille et tu
sois voilà plutôt sereine et quand quand
ta fille va naître on t'offre un nom
d'hôtel dans un quatre étoiles juste à
côté de chez toi à montélimar dans
laquelle tu vas pouvoir vivre pendant
donc un an avec ta fille je tiens à
remercier particulièrement la directrice
de l'établissement christelle stubert
histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah non
4 c'est la paix voilà c'est la chambre
doit pouvoir rallier un nom à l'hôtel ma
chérie je voulais te dire je serais
content je peux faire un énorme bisou je
te sens et ce sans contente donc je suis
content ça va tu étais content tu es
stressé mais techcrunch de fin gourmet
voulais dire c'est devenu une vraie
guerrière parce que la rue c'est pas
facile on est confronté aux problèmes
d'alcool a beaucoup de violence et elle
a développé une force dans son âge qui
est exceptionnel voilà et on voulait
surtout si dire natacha regarder elle a
20 ans elle pourrait être la fille de
tout le monde c'est une gamine qui se
tient qu'à s'en sortir et je voudrais
vous remercier tous les deux au travail
qu'on fait
merci infiniment pour tout ce que tu as
fait depuis des années
pour nous c'est extrêmement difficile et
s'entoure n'aurait pas on a pu obtenir
pourtant c'est notre petit est très dur
[Applaudissements]
et je peux dire que je convie ses
moments que tu dis à très difficile
parce qu'il ya plein de gens et là tout
à l'heure ma fille ma peur nous un papa
il ya un couple de personnes âgées
adultes avec deux petits enfants qui
dorment sur un sur un banc 123 rue de la
convention à paris dans le 15e est-ce
que de 10 heures du matin jusqu'au soir
sur ce banc dans le froid
donc j'ai envoyé une équipe tout à
l'heure faye ans n'était plus là bas et
on les lâche voilà bravo parce que les
enjeux il faut un travail magnifique
[Applaudissements]